you need to bet on your strengths and
don't give a [ __ ] about what you suck at
way too many people in this room are
gonna spend the next 30 40 years of
their lives trying to check the boxes
other things that they're not as good at
and that you're gonna waste a load of
time and lose I highly recommend
auditing yourself or if you have no
empathy or EQ or self-awareness then
find somebody in your family or
friendship that does and let them tell
you who you are and once you believe
that either for yourself or someone else
told you go directly all chips all into
that because that is the only possible
way that is a very highly likely way of
over-indexing because the truth is if
you want to be an anomaly you've got to
act like one how do you get money to do
what you love you don't i lost load of
money when i started doing what i loved
what you do is you position yourself to
succeed
so for example if you're doing something
else and you want to do this thing you
love you do it after hours you work 9 to
6 you get home you kiss the dog and you
go to town I mean you start building
your equity in your brand and whatever
you're trying to accomplish after hours
everybody has time stop watching lost if
you want this if you want bling bling if
you want to buy the Jets if you want to
do work that's how you get it you just
watched two amazing clips from Gary
Vaynerchuk take the next three minutes
to sit quietly and think about how you
can apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]